[Music]
ah first crushes we all remember them
and if you're a girl who grew up in the
90s your first crush might have been one
of the dream phone guys
[Music]
oh boy
i think gary he has kind of a nice smile
yeah i'd say matt's probably a jock
this is mike gray the unlikely inventor
of the ultimate 90s tween dating game we
needed a game targeted towards
nine-year-old girls it was a bunch of
guys
that did it but that's okay i know who
it is but i'm not jealous
i said let's do something that's kind of
like clue so it's deduction we're going
to call a bunch of boys because we heard
some boy likes us
[Music]
so it all started with the phone right
yes
we kind of laughed and we kind of called
this the pink slipper you know in its
day it was an elegant and beautiful
thing i know where he hangs out so how
did they pick the boys of your teenage
dreams we went to a photo house we
didn't know like who these boys were or
anything we just picked ones that we
liked
that's not the only 90s girls game mike
made he also made the super successful
maul madness but he's pretty real about
his influence as a guy well if i'm going
to make a game about shopping what i
know about shopping you just go get what
you need and get back to the car
later it was pointed out to me that
that's kind of not the way ladies shop
so it was kind of in a funny way a guy's
game you know
but it was for girls
i say games are togetherness in a box
play a game with people you learn a lot
about them and it shouldn't be about
winning and losing it should be about
being together
you